I am fall Gertz a professor at Yale Law
School and I'm here today Yale
University studios with an extraordinary
guest Justice Stephen Breyer of the
Supreme Court of the United States
Justice Breyer was appointed to the
court in 1994 by President Bill Clinton
prior to that he served on the faculty
at Harvard Law School for many years and
after that a judge on the United States
Court of Appeals in Boston becoming its
chief judge in 1990 and in between he
served in the Justice Department as
chief counsel the Senate Judiciary
Committee where he worked in a
leadership role in deregulating the
airline industries so he is someone who
brings to the Supreme Court
extraordinary experience within
government and experience as a
world-class scholar and he is today in
my judgment the most thoughtful of our
justices he is a great judge and it is a
tremendous privilege for us to welcome
you to Yale University and on behalf of
the whole Yale community Justice Breyer
we're just really delighted you could
you could join us oh thank you thank you
very much I'm very happy to be here
particularly when I get such a nice
introduction I thought I'd start with a
very basic question which is what you
think the American public should know
about the Supreme Court but one of the
most important things the public should
should know about the court I'd like the
public to know what we do I think lots
of people think that we randomly decide
on the basis of whatever we happen to
like what cases we want to hear and then
we decide them the way whatever we think
would be good that would be serious
misimpression the job of the Supreme
Court justice is to interpret the
Constitution that's part of it brief
document that governs the country and
federal law those are the laws passed by
Congress the statute
really probably 85% of the law is made
in the States and is not our concern
people don't understand that family law
most business law most criminal law
education these are state matters
primarily and they don't concern us
we're not involved in that law we are
involved in the laws passed by Congress
and this document now what should they
know about this document well it's
fairly short but I'm not going to read
the whole thing it has seven articles it
has 27 amendments what does it do well
but I'd like people to see is that it
doesn't tell us to tell everybody in the
country what to do rather it creates a
framework for government those it's a
constitution it constitutes a federal
government what does that mean in the
seven articles it tries to create a
framework for a democratic kind of
government a government where people
decide ordinary citizens what kinds of
rules they want for their community it
creates a Center the House of
Representatives a president they're all
now elected the point is that individual
Americans will decide themselves for
themselves in their communities that
states the nation what kind of laws they
want that's not our job it's a special
kind of democracy it's a democracy that
in addition to being democratic
guarantees basic rights
that's the Bill of Rights it guarantees
every citizen certain basic rights like
freedom of speech and so forth it
guarantees a certain degree of equality
it divides power and separates powers
state federal three branches so that no
single group of people becomes too
powerful and it insists upon the rule of
law so it only takes me about 30 seconds
I can't do it in five seconds but it
takes about 30 seconds
to describe this basic framework now
what is that framework they are
boundaries that sets the boundaries
beyond which government cannot go
government cannot oppress an individual
it cannot deprive a person of free
speech fair trial and so forth it cannot
go beyond the bounds of the powers that
are set here and we're the boundary
patrol that's what we do we're the
boundary patrol and as you look over the
history of the court what are some of
the leading examples of the courts most
important decisions where it carried out
that role for the good of the country
well sometimes you see the the virtue in
that I mean what I say we're the
boundary patrol I don't mean the cases
are easy life at the boundary in the
frontier sometimes difficult and their
arguments but within those boundaries
there are vast areas huge where people
decide for themselves what kinds of
communities they want so you're saying
what are a couple of examples where they
went beyond the boundaries no the most
obvious example were States and
sometimes the federal government went
well beyond the boundaries was when they
had legal segregation in the south of
the United States they said black people
go to one school white go to another
black people drink from one water
fountain white drink from another and I
can remember that time and maybe you can
where there was a total separation of
the race as well if you look at the
document it says here in amendment 14 no
state
shall deny any person the equal
protection of the laws no what you
looked at the south boy hey do is look
at those schools where black children
went they were shacks and look at the
ones where the white children went they
were much nicer but even if they hadn't
been different even if they'd been the
same still the segregation was saying to
black people in this country there's a
kind of badge of inferiority and
everyone knew that they looked at the
south it was terrible and in Brown
versus Board of Education the Supreme
Court said read these words equal
protection of the law well there are
large numbers of Americans who are not
getting equal protection of the law and
that is unlawful therefore you will have
schools that are integrated you will not
have schools that are segregated and the
whole legal system of segregation fell
it took a long time but it began with a
court decision in Brown versus Board of
Education in 1954 so if I had to pick
one of you two that would certainly be
one of them and at the other extreme if
you had to pick a mistake we're in our
constitutional mystery what would what
would you point through well the general
view of which is the worst and I think
this is a good candidate for the worst
was on the same issue the issue of race
and it was before the Civil War and it
was the court made a huge error no one
knows quite why maybe they were trying
to be political but there was a man Dred
Scott who was a slave and he sued for
his freedom he sued for his freedom on
the ground that he had lived in a free
territory he probably was right because
at that time before the Civil War even
though there was slavery if a slave
lived in a free territory long enough he
was free the Supreme Court took the case
and it was terrible they said even
assuming he's free even assuming he's
free because he is the descendant of
slaves he's not a person a citizen of
the United States and he can't bring a
suit in this court I was pretty bad
but he got worse after that they said
that the laws that Congress has passed
in order to prevent the spread of
slavery the Missouri Compromise among
others that those laws violate the
Constitution and then it got worse
because they said if a slave holder
comes with his slaves into a free
territory like New York or Massachusetts
that state cannot take the slave away
from him it's his property the slave is
a property human being but a slave my
goodness
that was a terrible decision and the
dissent in that decision pointed out
where do you find that in the
Constitution even the constitution of
the time even before the thirteenth
fourteenth and fifteenth amendments that
stopped slavery where do you find that
in the Constitution good question
I've read the opinion it's hard to find
an answer and then people got terribly
upset in the North particularly the New
York legislature passed a dinner issued
report we'd said my goodness after this
decision has become the law what will
happen is that that that that slave
driver with his manacled slave gang will
come to the foot of Bunker Hill the
symbol of freedom and we'll walk around
with these people in Chains and you may
be next I mean they were pretty annoyed
and pretty angry and the one good that
came out of it is it Abraham Lincoln
holding in his hand the dissent of
Benjamin Curtis gave a great speech at
Cooper's Union and became the champion
of the anti-slavery movement in America
the political champion obtained the
nomination of the Republican Party for
president and eventually though after a
terrible Civil War
eventually slavery was abolished but no
thanks to accept in an ironic sense no
thanks to Dred Scott I think that's
generally viewed as the worst so the two
examples show a high point in the courts
history and a low point
your lectures this week here are called
making the Constitution work what do you
what do you mean by that I mean it is an
unusual thing in the history of the
world it has been a pretty unusual thing
but nine unelected people who are judges
will decide and have really close to
final authority you can amend the
Constitution but it's pretty hard as to
what the meaning of this document is now
it's an extraordinary thing to what I
see every day in the court and the court
in front of me know in that room I see
every kind of person you can imagine I
see people of every race every religion
every point of view and they're there to
resolve their differences under law
under law differences that they could be
really angry about I mean think of how
people feel about abortion there are two
sides that in a very very very angry one
side of the other about the position of
the other side
what about prayer in schools what about
Bush vs. gore
people got very angry about those cases
and yet still by and large not always
but by and large people will perhaps
grudgingly complainingly thinking that
the courts totally wrong but they will
tend to follow the interpretation that
nine people who are human and very
fallible what those nine people give the
interpretation they give of this
document now there's a virtue in that
and the virtue in that is a country of
300 million people a very diverse
country with all kinds of different
points of view that in that country
those 300 million very different people
now we say 300 million people in 900
million opinions the 300 million people
will resolve their differences under law
and not with guns on the street or
through riots or throwing stones or
sticks or bullets or tanks at each other
now that is an amazing an amazing
treasure it's a it's a it's a blessing
for America and I want to show people in
that lecture yesterday that they cannot
take that for granted they never should
take that for granted it's something
that has to be worked on
that's gradually evolved over time
that's cost us a civil war we've had 80
years of legal legal segregation that
was this country all kinds of things
have gone wrong and yet the history of
this country is such that gradually one
of its virtues is that these 300 million
will decide things under law and I
wanted to show people enough so that
they can see that that's important and
it has to be continuously worked on and
as a justice what is it most important
to keep in mind in order to make the
Constitution work in order to sustain
that public trust over time knowing that
the court will from time to time issue
decisions that people will disagree with
well today I'm going to talk about that
I mean I don't think really if you're
going to maintain a world a country a
nation with a court and maintain a
system where people do tend to follow
the court even where what they do say is
unpopular and could be wrong if you're
going to maintain that primarily it's a
function of the people of the country
understanding the importance of it so
it's more a question of Education and
it's more a question of learning
something about politics in this country
about government about how it works
about participation it's more a question
of those things than it is anything the
court can do but that doesn't mean the
court can do nothing the court if it's
going to be trusted has to merit the
trust and to merit that trust I think
the court does not hold its finger up to
the political wind there would be no
point in having a court if it just held
its finger up to the political win why
do it we have a lot of people in country
better politicians than the nine on the
court that would be that would be crazy
but rather what the court can do I think
is to interpret the statutes and this
document in ways that work for people
who are living now when I try to
summarize that in a sentence I say it's
a question of recognizing that in this
document there are values that do not
change the values are permanent the
value of due process of law
the value of free speech the value of
protecting against unreasonable searches
and seizures the values that are
incorporated in this document are
permanent but how they apply that's a
different matter because life changes so
we have to apply permanent values to
changing circumstances that keeps this
Constitution meaningful and protective
for people who are alive today now how
to do that how to make law work well
without departing from the permanent
value how to make law work well for
Americans today well that's the subject
of what I'll talk about this afternoon
and in your time on the court more than
15 years at this point what what is the
case or two that stands out for you that
most represents the court doing this job
well and doing it importantly for the
country
I hesitate because you don't know
I mean yogi Berra's statements right he
said I never make predictions
particularly not about the future and
it's really the future you know that
will say whether we did our job right or
not I mean things always look right to
the people who do it they always look
right because if they didn't look right
why would they do it I mean it's it's a
question of what happens in the future
and people looking back I think and I
hope that the people will it will turn
out that when you evaluate if I had to
pick one set of cases I would say I
think the Guantanamo cases were pretty
important
and I hope that it will turn out that we
got decided them correctly now what
happened in those cases and there were
four is that the president in each case
was being sued by a detainee somebody
who was detained in three of them at
Guantanamo and in the fourth previously
at the time did a new one Montana moan
he'd been moved in each of those cases
the person who sued the president lost a
one and the president lost and in each
of those cases the court facing the
issue in front of us decided in favor of
the particular Liberty that the
individual detainee was advocating but
the opinions are narrow the opinions
don't reach too far because the court
there is making an effort to safeguard
the right of a very unpopular individual
one of them was Ben Laden's driver I
doubt there are many were less popular
than he but he had a right to come into
court he had a right not to be tried we
thought under the statute by a military
tribunal given the law as it was then
and he won his case we recognized at the
same time it's the president who has
authority to protect the nation in case
of war or serious national security
crisis so it's an effort to weave a line
if the court goes too far and it ties
the hands of a president in times of
real necessity it would be difficult for
the country but if it advocates its
responsibility and does nothing for an
individual who's being deprived of a
basic Liberty then why have such a court
what's it there for if not to protect
individuals who unpopular as they maybe
are being deprived of a right to which
they're entitled
I put the court to the test those cases
and we'll see how history evaluates
well certainly at the present moment it
appears that those cases illustrate the
court holding on to law protecting
individual rights doing it in a narrow
way as you said and quite remarkably
getting the public including the
President of the United States to accept
it well I think that when the court does
its job that the public will generally
approve because even though everyone
would like to have his or her way normal
it's normal part of the human condition
yet I think people when they stop to
think about it can accept an institution
the very point of which is to be
independent the very point of which is
to decide under neutral principles of
law to protect an individual possibly
even when that individual is very
unpopular I don't get my way today but
tomorrow that same law will protect me
if I'm the unpopular one people
understand that they know that's the
basic point of the institution and
therefore I think there is support for
it and what do you think of the most
serious problems facing the courts as a
whole in American life and playing that
role both in ordinary cases and in big
ones I think the the most serious
problem is what I would call maybe a
lack of interest to the point where
people don't know and don't understand
the judicial institution and the reason
that I fear that you know just an
ordinary person which I understand who's
not a judge you say I'm a judge and if
they politely say well what do you do
and you try to explain it they say oh
that's very interesting but actually it
would have got to get back to the
baseball game or whatever they're there
they're interested in it's sort of dull
to explain and complicated and but if
enough people don't understand it what
they'll tend to think of since we're
people who make decision so they're sort
of politicians and once they think the
judges are politicians I think we're in
trouble because if they think that there
won't be the ability if they think it
they'll make them politicians and if
they make them politicians there won't
be the ability to protect that unpopular
individual against a majority who's
trying to tyrannize and then the point
of the institution is lost I mean quite
honestly I've said this and certainly a
lot of my colleagues have in sandra
o'connor spending a lot of time at it
it's really quite shocking that in many
states where judges run for election
there are now huge campaign
contributions from one group or another
that favors this judge of the other
judge to the tune of millions of dollars
to get judges elected to the Supreme
Court of a state that's a dangerous
situation because it creates a reality
or at least the perception that these
judges are politically beholden to one
group or another to keep running for
office to collect the money and once
that perception catches on widely you
will not have an independent judiciary
which is bad for everyone so thank you
so much for coming thank thanks for
talking and we're all very grateful